point number two is gonna confuse you  because it's the complete opposite of  point number one which is what you don't  have any time let's go you gotta get  going you're getting older which in  reality  that's my message i'm an urgent guy i'm  a guy that's like let's go let's go  let's go but that message to a 45 year  old 50 year old who just went through a  divorce  who may be sitting around thinking this  is it for me life is over with i can't  do nothing about my life right now  that's also wrong because for you you  have to realize that in your mid 40s or  50s in today's time we're living a long  time the whole purpose of urgency to me  is don't take your time to figure out  whatever the solution may be to the  current challenge you're facing that's  the issue